FORD JR., DANA PERINO, AND
GREG GUTFELD.
THIS IS "THE FIVE."
♪ ♪
A HUGE BATTLE OVER VOTING TAKING
CENTER STAGE IN AMERICA.
A FEARMONGERING JOE BIDEN
SURVEYING REPUBLICANS AS RACIST,
AND CLAIMING DEMOCRACY IN
AMERICA IS UNDER SIEGE OVER
STATES LIKE TEXAS TRYING TO PASS
ELECTION INTEGRITY LAWS.
>> THE 21ST CENTURY JIM CROW
ASSAULT ISRAEL.
IT'S UNRELENTING.
AND WE ARE GOING TO CHALLENGE IT
VIGOROUSLY.
ARE YOU ON THE SIDE OF TRUTH OR
LIES?
FACT OR FICTION, JUSTICE OR
INJUSTICE CONNECT DEMOCRACY OR
AUTOCRACY?
THAT'S WHAT IT'S COMING DOWN TO.
STAND UP, FOR GOD SAKE, AND HELP
PREVENT THIS CONCERTED EFFORT TO
UNDERMINE OUR ELECTION.
HAVE YOU KNOW SHAME?
WE ARE FACING THE MOST
SIGNIFICANT TEST OF OUR
DEMOCRACY SINCE THE CIVIL WAR.
>> Jesse: JOE BIDEN IS ALSO
CALLING FOR A FEDERAL TAKEOVER
OF ELECTIONS AND IS PROMISING TO
USE HIS DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE TO
GO AFTER THE STATES.
NOW, KEEP IN MIND, WHILE THE
PRESIDENT SPEWED THAT KIND OF
RHETORIC, LIBERAL FACT-CHECKERS
HAVE FOUND THESE REPUBLICAN
BILLS ACTUALLY EXPAND VOTING
HOURS.
BUT THOSE FACTS DON'T MATTER TO
LIBERALS IN TEXAS.
A GROUP OF SHOWBOATING DEMOCRATS
JUST SKIPPING TOWN IN ORDER TO
BLOCK REPUBLICANS THERE FROM
PASSING THESE NEW VOTING BILLS.
THEY ARE FASHIONING THEMSELVES
AS POLITICAL MARTYRS, WHO OF
COURSE FLED THE THE DOWN NEXT
WASHINGTON, D.C., WITHOUT
FACE MASKS, AND A QUESADILLA.
WHILE THEY SOAK UP ATTENTION,
TEXAS GOVERNOR
GREG ABBOTT IS PROMISING TO
ARREST THEM WHEN THEY RETURN.
>> I WILL CONTINUE CALLING
SPECIAL SESSION AFTER A SPECIAL
SESSION BECAUSE OVERTIME IS
GOING TO CONTINUE TO VOTE.
THEY WILL BE ARRESTED AND
BROUGHT TO THE TEXAS BUY CAPITOL
AND WILL BE CONDUCTING BUSINESS.
>> Greg: WHAT JOE SAID TODAY
JUST UPSETS ME.
I MEAN, HE IS A PATHOLOGICAL,
SHAMELESS LIAR.
HE RAN ON BEING A UNIFIER, AND
ALL HE DOES HIS BANK ON RACIAL
DISCONTENT.
HE IS COMPARING THIS BILL TO THE
KKK, JIM CROW.
ALL HE DOES IS FOMENT RACIAL
CONFLICT.
HE CLAIMS HE'S MAKING A MORAL
CASE FOR VOTING RIGHTS AS IF
THERE ARE NO VOTING RIGHTS.
EVERY AMERICAN HAS THE RIGHT TO
VOTE, EXCEPT THE LESS FAVORED
VOTING BLOCS, WHICH ARE FELONS,
ILLEGAL IMMIGRANTS, AND THE
DEAD.
[LAUGHTER]
IS ONLY ONE TRUE POSSIBILITY OF
A ZOMBIE UPRISING, AND IT'S
BECAUSE THE CORPSES FOUND OUT
THEY VOTED FOR JOE BIDEN.
THE ONLY REPUBLICANS THEY KNOW
OF ARE EVIL.
RONALD REAGAN WAS SUPPOSED BE
THE WORST PAIN HE WAS HITLER.
THEN YOU HAVE GEORGE BUSH, A
WARMONGER PAID THAN THE OTHER
GEORGE BUSH, HE WAS A WARMONGER.
THEN JOHN McCAIN, WARMONGER,
AND MITT ROMNEY WAS GOING TO PUT
EVERYBODY BACK IN CHAINS.
THEN WE ARE SUPPOSED TO GET THE
BIGGEST, GREATEST EXISTENTIAL
RISK IN HISTORY OUT OF
DONALD TRUMP, AND NOW THAT'S A
LIE, BECAUSE HE'S GONE, AND NOW
THIS IS A BIGGER EXISTENTIAL
RISK THAN DONALD TRUMP.
THIS IS THE WORST THING SINCE
THE CIVIL WAR.
I'M BEGINNING TO THINK THEY ARE
EXAGGERATING.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jesse: WHAT GAVE YOU THAT
IDEA?
>> Greg: I DON'T KNOW!
I'M JUST LOOKING FOR THE NEXT
EXISTENTIAL RISK.
>> Jesse: JUDGE JEANINE, I
LOOKED THROUGH THE ENTIRE TEXAS
VOTING BILL, AND THERE'S NOT ONE
IN THERE THAT RESTRICTS VOTING.
>> Jeanine: THERE ISN'T.
IF YOU THINK ABOUT IT, THEY EVEN
BROUGHT ONE PERSON BEFORE YOU TO
TELL YOU THAT THIS PERSON WAS
NOT ABLE TO VOTE BECAUSE OF
THIS.
IN FACT, WHAT THEY WANT TO DO,
REMEMBER WHEN THEY EXPANDED
EVERYTHING BECAUSE OF THE
PANDEMIC?
THEY WANT TO KEEP THE PANDEMIC
VOTING AND WHAT MAKES ME CRAZY
IS YOU HAVE THESE TEXAS
LEGISLATORS TO MAKE THE DECISION
THAT THEY'RE GOING TO GO TO
WASHINGTON, D.C.
I MEAN, IT IS SUCH AN
EMBARRASSMENT TO TEXANS.
I KNOW A LOT OF PEOPLE FROM
TEXAS, I LOVE A LOT OF PEOPLE
FROM TEXAS, OKAY?
BUT ONE THING THEY DON'T DO IS
CUT AND RUN.
THEY DON'T RUN TO DADDY IN
WASHINGTON AND SAY, "DADDY, HELP
US, WE WANT TO DO OUR JOB AND
FEDERALIZE THE ELECTION LAWS."
WHO GAVE YOU THAT RIGHT?
GET BACK TO WORK.
PEOPLE VOTED FOR YOU TO WORK ON
LEGISLATION.
YOU TRIED TO STOP THE REGULAR
SESSION, THEY COULDN'T GET
ANYTHING TO PASS, AND THEY ARE
DOING IT FOR THE SPECIAL
SESSIONS.
THESE PEOPLE ARE AN
EMBARRASSMENT.
LOOK AT THEM, THEY LOOK LIKE
THEY'RE GOING TO CAMP.
I CAN GUARANTEE THERE IS
MILLER LITE ON THAT PLANE.
STEPHEN THERE IS.
>> Greg: THEY HAD TO BUY THE
DEER.
OBVIOUSLY THE TAXPAYERS.
>> Jesse: SO HOW DOES IT LOOK
RIGHT NOW, THE DEMOCRATS FLEEING
TO WASHINGTON?
I BELIEVE KAMALA HARRIS IS GOING
TO BE MEETING WITH THESE FLEEING
DEMOCRATS.
I DON'T KNOW WHEN, BUT WE'LL
COVER HERE IN SHOW.
>> EVERYONE HAS RAISED AT THE
RIGHT POINTS.
>> Jeanine: I LIKE YOU, THIS
IS THE FIRST TIME WE'VE BEEN
TOGETHER!
>> Greg: KEEP YOUR HANDS OFF
HIM.
[LAUGHTER]
>> Jeanine: I'M SORRY!
>> Harold: YOU HAVE TO ASK THE
QUESTION, WHAT DO WE WANT WHEN
YOU HAVE AN ELECTION CONNECT TO
YOUR POINT, DURING THE PANDEMIC
WE MADE IT EASIER FOR PEOPLE TO.
I HAPPEN TO THINK WHAT YOU WANT
IN ANY ELECTION -- AND I'VE WON
IN FIVE ELECTIONS, I LOST ONE.
I WISH WE COULD HAVE FOUND MORE
PEOPLE TO VOTE AND MAKE THE
CLAIMS THAT FORMER
PRESIDENT TRUMP IS MAKING.
I WANTED MORE PEOPLE TO VOTE AND
THEY DIDN'T.
IT TURNS OUT THAT THEY WON THIS
TIME.
IF YOU HAVE A SET OF SYSTEMS IN
PLACE TO ENCOURAGE THAT AND
VALIDATED GOING FORWARD, I THINK
WE SHOULD.
POLITICS, TOO MUCH THEATER.
TRAVELING TO D.C. I GET THE
POLITICS, THE THEATER OF THE
POLITICS.
WE ALL ENGAGE IN A LITTLE OF
THAT TO MAKE OUR POINT.
I REMINDED HER THAT HE, 60
FEDERAL STATE COURTS DENIED
THESE CLAIMS.
IT HAS BEEN MORE SCRUTINY AROUND
THIS PRESIDENTIAL RACE.
THE GUY WANTED TO WIN WON.
HAD HE LOST, I WOULD HAVE
ACCEPTED IT AND MOVED ON.
I THINK AT SOME POINT THEY NEED
TO ACCEPT THERE WAS AN ELECTION,
PRESIDENT BIDEN WON, AND IF WE
ARE SERIOUS ABOUT MORE PEOPLE
VOTING, LET'S PUT EFFORTS
FORWARD AND CHANGES TO ELECTION
LAWS THAT ALLOW MORE PEOPLE TO
VOTE AND NOT MAKE IT HARDER FOR
PEOPLE TO VOTE.
>> Dana: WHAT PEOPLE?
>> Jesse: HAROLD, LET ME ASK
YOU A SPECIFIC QUESTION.
WHERE IN THE TEXAS BUILDERS AND
MAKE IT HARDER FOR PEOPLE TO
VOTE?
>> Harold: TWO THINGS, TO
ANSWER QUESTION.
NUMBER ONE, WE ROLL BACK SOME OF
THE PANDEMIC ACCOMMODATIONS THAT
WERE THERE TO MAKE IT EASIER FOR
PEOPLE TO VOTE.
>> Jesse: WHAT DID THEY DO TO
MAKE IT HARDER FOR PEOPLE TO
VOTE?
>> Dana: 24-HOUR VOTING IN
HOUSTON, IT WAS SUPPOSED TO BE
ALLOWED AND THEY DID IT.
FOR ONE EXAMPLE.
>> Harold: WE CAN GO LINE BY
LINE AND THE BILL, BUT THERE IS
NO DOUBT THERE ARE EFFORTS THAT
ARE DIFFERENT FOR THE 2022 AND
'24 ELECTION.
>> Greg: IF YOU ARE SAYING
THEY ARE ROLLING BACK, THAT'S
NOT TRUE, BECAUSE THEY ARE
ADDING MORE TIME TO VOTE.
MAYBE THEY TOOK AWAY THE 24-HOUR
RULE, BUT THERE ARE WAY MORE
HOURS ON EARLY VOTING I
THINK -- I'M NOT SAYING IT'S NOT
A SERIOUS TOPIC, BUT I THINK
IT'S ACTUALLY SOMETHING TO BE
RIDICULED AND LAUGHED AT.
IF NOTHING PASSES, THE STATE
REVERTS BACK TO PRE2020.
IF THAT --
>> Greg: SOMEBODY READ THE
PACKET!
[LAUGHTER]
>> Dana: THE DEMOCRATS OR FOR
RESTRICTIONS, BECAUSE IT WOULD
BE PRE2020.
OUR NEW THINGS IN HERE.
THE SUPREME COURT JUST RULED
LAST WEEK OR THE WEEK BEFORE
THAT NOT A SINGLE PERSON COULD
BE SHOWN TO HAVE BEEN HARMED IN
ARIZONA WHEN IT CAME TO VOTING
RESTRICTIONS.
SO THE SUPREME COURT SAID NO,
YOU CAN'T SHOW AN ACTUAL PERSON
HAS BEEN HARMED, AND YOU CAN'T,
THAT WAS YOUR POINT THERE.
BUT ALSO THE TEXAS DEMOCRATS
REALLY DIDN'T THINK THIS
THROUGH.
THEY MADE ARRANGEMENTS FOR
PRIVATE JETS, HOTEL ROOMS, THEY
SCHEDULED THEIR TV INTERVIEWS,
BUT THEY DIDN'T HAVE A
COMMUNICATIONS MEETING.
THEY HAD SIMPLY NO MESSAGE AT
ALL.
SO THEY END UP DOING STEP ONE,
GET ON A PLANE, GET SOME BEER,
TAKE A LOT OF SELFIES.
[LAUGHTER]
LEAVE THAT BLANK, LET'S FILL
THAT IN LATER, AND STEP THREE,
WHEN THE FIGHT.
THEY ARE TRYING TO PLAY POWER
POLITICS WITH NO POWER.
THERE IS NO STRATEGY.
THEY NEED A MITCH McCONNELL
WHO CAN CALMLY SAY, "THIS IS THE
GOAL WE WANT TO GET TO COME OF
THIS IS WHAT WILL BE ABLE TO
DO," THEN YOU WORK BACKWARDS.
THESE GUYS I LIKE, "WELL, WE
WILL STAY IN D.C. FOR AN
INDETERMINATE PERIOD.
PLEASE SEND MORE MONEY SO THEY
CAN STAY IN HOTELS."
IN THEIR FUND-RAISING LIKE
CRAZY.
>> Greg: WHERE ARE THEIR
MASKS?
>> Jeanine: NOT ONLY THAT,
THEY'RE GOING TO BE THERE FOR 26
DAYS.
THAT'S WHEN THIS SPECIAL SESSION
IS ENDING.
THEY'RE NOT GOING BACK, WHO IS
PAYING FOR THIS HOTEL?
DEMOCRATIC SOCIALISTS OF